thank you very much Hannah thanks to all
of you coming just hearing their about
the agenda coming up it sounds as if
that's perfectly timed because I think
election nights tend to be when Russia
does indeed come in from the cold so
that's obviously very very good planning
there we have a subject before us though
which is could not be more pertinent for
our time you'll have known that the
Oxford English dictionary's word of the
year for 2016 was post truth you'll also
know that there are three books no less
than three you no fewer than three
rather that have come out right now on
that subject and central to any argument
about this post truth landscape is fake
news and that is the subject before us
and it's going to be discussed by six
people all expertly placed either
practitioners in the news business all
people who are monitoring and closely
looking at how we get our information
and what might be done about it another
formal debate with a motion to be
discussed instead it is a discussion
where we're going to hear these
conflicting and competing arguments over
here and then in our final segment we're
going to open it out to all of you for
thoughts and contributions so before we
get to introducing our very stellar
panel I thought I would do a little fake
news survey if you like with all of you
and I'm going to ask for a show of hands
when I give you first of all three
stories all of which in 2016 went viral
but only one of which is actually true
and I'm going to ask you to raise your
hands when you hear the true one that's
the deals now so I'm going to read you
I'm not gonna read you I'm just going to
tell you three things that went viral
over the last in 2016
and you have to raise your hand when you
think which of these stories is true so
the first one is that the Pope during
the 2016 election campaign endorsed
Donald Trump any takers for that
none for that the second story that went
viral clip that went around the internet
featured Donald Trump saying he would
date his daughter Ivanka if only he
wasn't married
oh you know very good and the third one
says that Hillary Clinton ran a child
sex ring from the basement of a pizza
restaurant in Washington DC's very very
good so that tells me what kind of
audience and indeed what kind of panel
we have so that that gets us going let
me then without further ado introduce to
you our panel who we're going to hear
from very quickly first up and on the
physical far-right of this panel is a
professor at Columbia Law School and a
former adviser in the Obama White House
his most recent book which I can tell
you is on sale after this event outside
this venue is the attention merchants
how our time and attention are gathered
and sold in 2013 he was named one of
America's 100 most influential lawyers
he is kim woo
next to him is with one of this
country's most successful comedy writers
he co-created the legendary Alan
Partridge and wrote the political comedy
series the stick of it the film in the
loop and was the showrunner on the White
House hit comedy veep he is Armando
Iannucci
you already gave her a warm welcome when
she arrived she is currently the editor
of BBC Radio 4's Today programme and
celebrated rebels in the title of George
Osborne's predecessor as the former
editor of the Evening Standard Saracen
on my left as I've often felt is a
journalist nor foe with a regular column
in The Spectator a contributor to
Breitbart news and his books include how
to be right the essential guides to
making lefty liberals history a warm
welcome for James Delingpole
and completing our i'll completing our
physical panel because there's somebody
else joining us by video link if
somebody who services i suppose every
single person in this room uses every
single day he is of course the founder
of Wikipedia the online not-for-profit
encyclopedia who has now set himself a
new task in order to fight fake news
he's recently launched wiki Tribune a
news website which will bring together
Professional Journalists and volunteers
working together to create fact checks
and reliable news he is Jimmy Wales
and completing our panel live from a
wall via video Lee he's the media editor
of BuzzFeed news where he leads bud
speeds analysis of fake news training
journalists all over the world in
verification and debunking of news
depending whether it's true or false the
author of regret the error how media
mistakes pollute the press and in peril
free speech I'm hoping we have a video
linked to Craig Silverman
good so what we're going to do is hear
an opening sort of case or oh just an
opening answer really from the brief and
to the point from each of our speakers
and Tim where I'm going to go to you
first because I think with any question
like this it helps to begin with the
definition so define for us what we talk
about Tim Wu what is faking you sure
that's a great question that's not quite
a bit of time looking into the history
of the news in particular of fake news
and I think there's two main categories
of fake news that you see emerging in
the history depending on their
motivation
the first is commercially fake news this
usually arises when you have a business
model that as most media do that depends
on on gathering up human attention where
you change the facts to make a story
more commercially appealing to make to
get in more readers so the first example
I was able to find out of this was the
New York Sun in the 1830s reported in a
six-part series what did it sound on the
moon among the things it found where
tall you trees like those in England
giant lakes and most important man bats
which were creatures like us but capable
of flight and fond of fornication so
that was an example the motive of this
was pretty clearly to drive circulation
of the newspaper and this was the first
newspaper New York Sun it was completely
depend on advertising and so you can see
this sort of commercially motivated fake
news you just make up better facts as
they're more interesting the second kind
of thing news is different and used to
be called and has its origins in
atrocity propaganda so and I think the
pioneer of this was frankly this country
and its newspapers and some of its the
propaganda ministries in the First World
War and this is where you make stories
fake stories for political or strategic
reasons so during the First World War
there was enormous stories of the
atrocities committed by the Germans
against the Belgians the big thing
constant publication many of these
stories were never in
the Germans entailed children on
bayonets and sang songs about it many
stories clearly made up that were never
verified and and used for obvious
political reasons so those are the two
motivations and I think today what's
happened as they come together you know
so many of our outlets you know Facebook
and Google who aren't here as examples
depend so heavily on traffic clicks time
on site attention frankly that they have
a commercial motivation to want to have
fake news and then there's a lot of
people still and have always been to
have a political reason to want to have
big news you know for more than one
reason but essentially I think that a
trusty element is there as well so it's
come together and that's our modern-day
thinking is very good thank you well we
were definitely get you to expand on
that
Craig Silverman I hope you can hear us
well you're this is an area that you
study closely you're able to give us a
new you know how you can tell the
difference between a story that might
have a couple of inaccuracies in it and
something you would put those slap the
label on a fake news and then perhaps
while you're doing that just explain to
us on what sort of scale of threat you
think this poses to democracy in to our
way of life ready yeah hello hello
everyone so I do think it's similar to
what Tim said putting that label of fake
on something for me it has to be
completely fabricated as you noted there
are often frequently news reports that
have some type of factual error in them
and that's a very common thing I spend
about a decade looking at mistakes in
the media and journalists we do make a
lot of mistakes there's no question
about that but there is a difference as
Tim said of something that is
deliberately created to deceive people
and I do think the commercial piece is
an important thing to note in the in
media environment we're seeing right now
in terms of the impact on it you know
one of the things that I think it does
on a really basic level is it increases
the amount of confusion that we have in
the information space when you have
stuff that is true or mostly true and
then you have things that are completely
false and they're sometimes built around
the same storylines or event that
creates a lot of confusion for people I
think it also has a role in
to pull it further politically
polarizing people someone who is already
a bit to the left or a bit to the right
they start to consume things that are
along those lines and a little more
extreme and over time they can
potentially become more polarized
because it's feeding them further those
views I do think one of the things that
in the wake of the u.s. election was
maybe taken too far as the idea that
Trump was elected because of state news
I don't think that's the case I do think
it may have pushed some people who are
already polarized maybe a little bit
further and it certainly created a lot
of confusion in the information space
but I don't know that it's necessarily
going to change someone's mind unless
you know there is a huge amount of
exposure on a constant basis thank you
and that's hopeful Amanda to you you
have made your name writing satirical
fiction often political fiction is it
harder looking into the events of the
last year to separate fiction from fact
and it almost because fact is almost
outstripping anything you could have
made up yes that's one of the reasons
I'm grateful that I gave up doing V
because I no longer find the situation
in America funny I found it depressing
yes and there are stories happening now
that that we would have considered when
we were writing these shows and then I
would have rejected them as being too
silly for example I think it was a you
kick I might got this wrong it was
certainly a candidate in the election
yesterday was advocating reintroducing
capital punishment for suicide bombers
which general media is a sort of and and
I was looking at but I find Trump and
and he's he's taken this I was watching
him and his it's the brazen way in which
he takes fact and fiction and mixed the
two that increased me he talks about
recently for how this what did you do
with your hundred first hundred days was
a nonsense and it was a terrible false
target it was artificial he wasn't
interested and he said this at a speech
at a rally given to mark his first
hundred days and as I was watching him I
was thinking this is this is the problem
because when you're writing comedy
you're writing distortions and
exaggerations you take
it's true and you bend it and twist it
until it becomes ridiculous but that's
what he does in every sentence he speaks
so he is his own sort of self basing
basting satirist really yes and
therefore what do we do and is
interesting that that the comedians who
have had any kind of impact are the ones
who have actually taken the opposite
view and gone okay well let's look at
facts
let's examine facts let's hire a team of
journalists and researchers let's look
at the archive I'm talking people like
John Oliver and Bill Maher and always
drinking it back to the actual core of
the truth rather than all the twisting
yes or you could be careful what you
mean by the truth I mean truth has now
become so subjectively but I think what
they're doing is say okay let's examine
the fact and one thing that John Oliver
did pull up was a clip of Newt Gingrich
in the last election being asked being
big saying people are worried because
crime is going up and the reporters say
no no no crime is going down no no no
you say crime has gone up and she said
no no the figures show the factual that
crime is going down and he said I know
but people feel crime is going up and
that's what matters yeah I mean there's
a risk of this becoming a philosophy
seminar but I just want to know the
difference in your mine because you made
a distinction just there between facts
you said it's different from truth all
right ok so just tell me what are you a
little bit truth you know we we like to
think that truth is absolute but it's
not any scientist will tell you that a
theory that becomes accepted is accepted
because it's the most recently and most
so far foolproof theory that explains
what's happening but it may well be
superseded by an even more complex and
enlightening theory I'm not saying that
I'm just wonder whether we're on the
verge of finding out that you know truth
rather like the atom is slightly and
definable until somebody interprets it
and as soon as you interpreted it starts
big in terms as a fact it's the
interpretation you put on a fact that we
consider right what is true what is not
true again we may want to pick up with
that for more and this to you
and you've worked for the what Donald
humbled revile is the mainstream media
so hate adventure medium print and in
broadcast now both what change of you
noticed all challenge almost has a fake
can use posed to that's even directly as
they've been stories that are running
that you think of faking yet you're sort
of they going viral and you're thinking
how do we cover this what we do so what
impact is faking use having on the news
landscape view
Cynthia you know you occupy a pretty
central positioning which I think it's a
big opportunity there was a conversation
I overheard yesterday of someone saying
work where do you get your what's your
news source which is a question people
are snow and and the guy said oh I go to
Google News and then I go to a trusted
source and I think that is that you know
that's it's that sort of interesting
distinction and for I mean that the the
BBC you're quite the sort of Holy Orders
side of all this so and I'm the BBC's
entire reputation stance on it being a
trusted source so it's just not worth
the risk part for anything else so you
know even talking about Manchester you
know for instance where there's a great
obviously and pouring of information and
not a bit wrong but but the idea that
you don't have to be first you had to be
right is is very helpful actually that's
exactly we you to double-checking and
triple-checking some of those reports
that were coming in on Manchester in a
way that was almost with it even more
vigilant than it might have been done
much more for you than I'd ever seen
oh yeah I'm a degree of vigilance is a
because the entire reputation of the BBC
stands on it or on it being trusted and
particularly now in here are taken
particularly now though that's your so
that's really your the virtu net and I
think that's you know that that's too in
and slightly different degrees elsewhere
you know that actually mainstream media
pot cementing else newspapers having
thought they were on their sort of
deathbed for a while you know there's a
glimmer of hope now because the
advertising may come back is one thing
so you're hearing from three different
people there till four actually chains
telling all that you know state news one
way and another is an issue
it's a problem how serious a problem is
it giving um I'm sorry to say this to
everyone here but you're wasting or
evening um
fake news is fake news Tim quite rightly
said that the beta news has been with us
in one form or another for well for
centuries big have always been making
stuff up for propaganda purposes or to
blacken the reputation of their their
enemies and there's a line that goes
from the the blood libel told against
the Jews the idea that the Jews were
going about murdering Christian children
drinking their blood right the way to
the protocols of the Elders of Zion for
example is fabrication many many
centuries later you can look at things
like the recent if 4chan scam where they
got revenge on their feminist enemies by
persuading them that there was this
thing happening that women were going
around not wearing tan taxes or panty
pads as a kind of feminist statement it
wasn't actually true they gold some poor
women into into thinking of was a thing
with embarrassing consequences they're
all there is there is all manner of fake
news around and that always has been but
I would say that the name we've given to
it is inaccurate what it really should
be called is sour grapes and the reason
I say that is that the first time I
heard of fake news and it really was but
it's quite a recent phrase before that
the current phrase was post factual post
truth there was a kind of meme going on
among the liberal left that that
right-wing people were making stuff up
the new version I first came upon when I
was invited on to the BBC to discuss the
fake news phenomenon and I was going to
say the things I'm going to say to you
tonight which is basically look left and
right people you know the competing
political visions will always write
stuff which is slanted but that's how it
goes but instead the first question that
BBC asked me was do you believe that
Donald does that Barack Obama was born
in Hawaii so they automatically imagine
that because I write for
an American conservative website that I
am prone to these conspiracy theories
the two obvious examples and the under
and the reason I was the fake news ur
issue came up at all on the BBC it came
just after the brexit result and I
noticed that the fake news mean was I
would consider it coincides with the
fact that Donald Trump won and he wasn't
expected to and brexit happened and that
this wasn't expected to at least among
the the established media they were
shocked and they needed an excuse just a
couple of stories I mentioned at the
beginning because you're skeptical about
the idea there is fake news those you
know the Pope endorsing Trump did go
round it was shared widely and this
claim that so-called Pizza Gator there
was a sex ring run from the base of
Israel if you don't ever think that
state news how would you describe those
two stories I think that the the the
fake element is that it the idea that is
in any way new or problematic it's just
a fashionable name for an old phenomenon
I don't believe that in the for example
the brexit vote was swung by the fact
that people wrote 350 million pounds
inside of a bus where I'm always told
this by by Ramona's in the same way I
don't believe it was the Russians that
swung it for Donald Trump these are just
excuses faint news is justin is not a
problem and I get the point might have
been not new but let's say that
allegation about the child fixing why is
that not a problem about the the people
who believe the the pizza party then
story I think we're already predisposed
to hate Hillary Clinton I don't think
these that these were kind of natural
voters who were suddenly sway it might
not have a political impact all right
let's them go to you Jimmy Wales and the
you know you started this new venture
with the Tribune and I know we want to
get as our discussion goes on beyond
just diagnosing the problem we do want
to do well our possible remedies
accepting for the sake of this
competition that it is a problem and
you're already in the business of coming
up with the remedy so what do you tell
us what your plan is and yeah so wiki
Tribune is a new news platform
and it's an effort to bring together
paid professional journalists and a wiki
style community to work together side by
side as equals to produce something new
in the in the field of news and so the
idea is to tap into deep networks of
expertise of quality people out there
but also have professional journalists
doing the kinds of things that it's been
difficult or impossible for citizen
journalists to do but I think equally
important to that and part of the reason
for that or part of the thing about that
is we turn the business model of
journalism has become incredibly
difficult and we know that the business
model is driving a lot of the low
quality things that we see from fake
news that I would equate equivalent to
to spam I mean people just generating
stuff that gets shared widely for no
other reason than to get clicks to
clickbait headlines in various local
media and that's driven by advertising
only business model and so the only the
only way to get money is to get lots and
lots of eyeballs looking at something
which drives you in a certain direction
and the high costs of journalism make it
very hard to do quality work when you
know you can only get slivers of revenue
here and there and so the idea is to
have no advertising but to have the the
readers contribute to become monthly
supporters and that actually suddenly
radically changes the business model as
you think about what it what kind of
things do we need to do so the BBC for
example the business model of the BBC
depends ultimately on the public
accepting the license fee and so they
don't have to chase clicks all the time
in the same way that other outlets may
be forced to you have outlets like
BuzzFeed who do actually an admirable
job of doing actual journalism but in
the early days of BuzzFeed it was quite
famous it being really good at clickbait
headlines and viral content and you know
somehow for some reason they decided to
do journalism as a as a side thing I
don't know why probably cost a lot of
money but interesting because when you
talk to people about you know in the
business of journalism they'll say
look we really you know we're
journalists we want to produce quality
work I wonder a lot of pressure just to
get clicks and give them as cheaply as
possible and that's that's a fundamental
problem with the model good we're going
to hear more about your proposal in the
course of the evening
Craig supplement I hope you're hearing
all this I mean I just want to put you
know at least two people have raised the
idea that it's not wholly new that
they've you know oil history is replete
with examples of propaganda and and even
lies in the news and yet we do have this
new term and approaching it with new
urgency and so I'm just wanting to hear
from you a sort of sharpened distinction
between what we're grappling with now
and what we had in the past and whether
maybe it's just because it goes viral so
much more easily because of the Internet
yeah I mean there's no disputing that
misinformation has existed for a very
long time there's also I think no
disputing that the media has played a
role in spreading false information at
times throughout history so what's
different well what's different is we
have a platform like Facebook that
almost two billion people log into every
month and that platform can make things
get the piece of content news get
tremendous velocity and as you say go
viral and what's happened is because
Facebook is such a massive traffic
generator it is a huge target for
spammers and people who want to exploit
it for economic means and so what's
happened is that news and traffic in
order to monetize them people are coming
up with different approaches on Facebook
to try and get that traffic to make
money from ads and so the economic model
for misinformation is probably more
appealing and more global now than it's
ever been that is definitely something
that's different I mean whether it's you
know teenagers and Macedonia spammers
that I've encountered in Vietnam or
possible around the world you have
people who are trying to weaponize
information in order to make money off
of it and one of the interesting things
which I think toom alluded to in the
election was that you know arguably some
of the propaganda stuff and actually the
financially oriented based news were
kind of identical the pro-trump stuff
was apparently perhaps something that
Russia might have been trying to help
influence again I don't think Russia
flipped the election but that stuff was
exactly the same as what the Macedonian
teens were doing because that's what are
in the money
for them so we have a completely
different media environment that is
democratized that it's dominated by
massive platforms that can make
information go viral and you layer into
that also the fact that there's a
tremendous amount of automation going on
there are BOTS
spreading false and fake information so
there are absolutely different elements
to it the reach of it and the velocity
of it is absolutely different and also
the economic piece I think is different
as well a lot of those elements have
been there before they're just kind of
supercharged now and we should mention
because Craig mentioned Facebook that we
did indeed contact and seek
representative from Facebook on the
panel tonight and despite our best
efforts they repeatedly declined our
invitation and so not here but I just
thought I'd mention that since since
Craig you mentioned who would like to
pick up particularly anything Craig said
I mean I hope you will Tim and one thing
I'm interested in is the notion of
whether or not it makes it he was saying
Craig that there's whether it's
political or commercial in a way he
doesn't make that much difference often
made up in the same place and I made
that distinction right at the beginning
I'm just wondering if in how we deal
with it we would deal with them
differently because you know because
their origin and their motive yeah
different one I think I think they have
converged because the commercial
incentives the ones that Jimmy was
talking about have made it profitable
for some platforms to push out which
previously is that which government will
be pushing out you know gut propaganda I
mean I think fake news and propaganda is
very closely related I want to take
issue with this idea that because you
know we've had fake news propaganda
historically that it's not a problem you
know we've had cancer for a long time
also you know it's a problem you can
have something can be historic and still
needs to be fought over and over and
over again and I you know even though
it's been used occasionally by by
Western societies I do associate the
extensive use of propaganda with fascist
ideologies and also with some of the
most repressive political systems we've
seen in history and that's what I'm
really concerned about I think fake news
and propaganda I think I'd like to call
a propaganda are tied with because of
the efforts to sort of glorify victory
because of the
ease with which you can use fake news to
accuse your opponent of atrocities and
try to destroy them but I think it is
closely linked to whatever has gone by
names fascist or totalitarian ideologies
over time so I think we're fighting
something more seriously than just like
errors in journalism or they're trying
to do error correction we are fighting
fascism we are fighting domination by
authoritarian figures and that's why I
think the fake news matter it's light
really matters remember you wanted to
come well only and I want to pick up and
kind of agree with Fleming James saying
in terms of I think there's a sweet I
think there's a danger if we think that
fake news is just right-wing because it
kind of lets us off it puts us in a
position of divorce from the political
arena and and leaving certain people
certain view as the enemy and certain
other people with another view as as the
good guys and I don't think that's right
the reason I went into making something
like the thick of it was a thing that
Tony burr said when he was trying to
justify the invasion of Iraq and the
fact that nothing was found
he said his party conference that he did
it because he thought it was the right
thing to do and he said he said I only
know what I believe which if you think
about it is the opposite of what most
people have done for that 3,000 years
which is examine and then and but what
he raised was that thing of belief faith
and it sort of talked about earlier
feeling if we just feel that way it's
placing that in the same level in fact
and that is something that happens
across the spectrum it's not Nestle
right now sure the Macedonian bloggers
and Phaeton use Smith's if they had
discovered a way of making money out of
Hillary Clinton being president would
have started to circulate stuff about
Donald Trump no I think I think there's
a danger we think this to Easi as a
problem or that it's just located with a
certain identifiable group of people
really I want to bring in Jim in a
second but just one thing I wondered
about because we having talked about
click page and I know the VC doesn't
have to be in that business but you say
partly from the
very strict and sort of plain facts of a
story I'm never going to be as exciting
and as interesting and sort of viral as
one of these made-up stories you know
that thing about the Pope endorsing
Trump was just compelling who wouldn't
want to read that and that the facts
might be just a bit more dull always
compared to fakie which I remember and
my daughter saying that she got her news
I think from YouTube and she said she
didn't know if it was true or not and
she didn't mind you know because it was
she took it as sort of entertainment bro
and so it's like easy it's what you want
from from this I think now people you
know dull is suddenly fine I think
people that are getting used to dull but
the thing about I mean lately respective
definition of terms and what what space
news have actually sort amazing stuff up
and what is selected to soar you know
which is something you could accuse
newspapers though it depends what your
your view is and therefore you find
facts to fit it and actually the belief
that you mentioned crime is a very
interesting one so the police do deal
with that you know we know that actually
putting two policemen on a street
walking up and down as a total is pretty
quite wasteful of that you know much
better half you know intelligence-led
policing but people feel reassured you
know so I don't if they feel we're
should now seeing the army on the street
that's that's a that's a discussion but
so some things have to be too and
politics is a lot about what people feel
as well as a lot of people think so I
think you have to be slightly more sort
of imaginative in your in your act that
you can't just say just facts are facts
yeah you know that was you need to tell
a story right Jim you wanted to come in
so I mean one of the things that I
wanted to point out and actually I think
James might very much agree with this
point which is one of the reasons so I
absolutely do think that of the majority
of the true fake news that we've seen
out there does tend to lean to the right
and that is that combination of both
commercial and political and if we want
to understand why that is right there's
a very comfortable out of touch
metropolitan elite view that well it's
just because people on the right have
very poor analytical
skills at understanding what's true and
false great totally missing the point
I didn't you aren't supposed to group of
that part good no but what is missing
the point there is that there is a
hunger by the public that there are
certain views which are to the right of
London whether they be on breakfast
there's a certain bunch of people who
are very unhappy with Hillary Clinton
and actually had a lot of appeal in the
policies of Trump although I find that
harder to quite grasp because I can't
figure out what his policies are he's so
random every day but and I do think that
there has been a problem with a media
echo chamber there's really right on
insufficient levels of self
introspection and debate about whether
we're taking into account all segments
of society appropriately which means
there is a group of people out there who
who are susceptible to politically
driven fake news a very hyped up news
you know and they are well served by
certain markets even though you might
stop I can look at it while this is
really not this is not quality
information and there there is something
wrong you know that we're not as the
mainstream media and I'm in this country
I would say for example the Daily Mail
is incredibly popular and it's very much
out of step with sort of the rest of the
median you know I have social friends in
common with you you and you and you know
that sort of world they've got a market
for it and there's a reason for it I
think you mentioned the Daily Mail I
mean Wikipedia got a lot of attention
for making a decision that the Daily
Mail would no longer count as a reliable
or trustable source
right I mean is that because you believe
what was in the mail was fake news
I think fake news is that is a a very
strong term I would reserve that term to
be really you know quite specifically
made up out of thin air that they wholly
fabricated wholly fabricated but there
are many examples in the Daily Mail of
stories that are false and still on the
website today they like to brag about
how few Press Complaints Commission that
whatever they are upheld against them
that's mostly because the stuff where
they leave the stories up there's nobody
to actually sue them one of my favorite
is a great you've got to do this so when
you go home Google China giant TV smog
and there's this fantastic photo in the
Daily Mail of a giant billboard
television with a picture of the sunrise
and the headline says something like
China forced to put up giant TV so
people can watch the sunrise due to the
smog it's a great story right and it
ticks a lot of boxes of our prejudices
about China and pollution it's the other
it's a very Daily Mail story it's also
completely false and has been widely
debunked but there's nobody to sue like
there's nobody they didn't libel you and
you didn't get on why how dare you and
then they go okay I'll take it down it
just sits there and you know there there
are a lot of cases like that where I
wouldn't call it fake news exactly but
it's not quality journalism Craig oh so
I just want to go to Craig Hillman just
for a second I want you in a way to
respond to the question that Sarah's
daughter raised which was the idea that
you know she checks the news and in a
way not that bothered whether it's true
or not it's entertaining and I'm
wondering what actually to you is the
sort of cost of people reading things
that they don't necessarily believe
they're true they enjoy them and they
mark their label news but then they may
be likable what's the actual public harm
here well I think it's going to depend
on the story itself in some cases I mean
if we think of classic tabloids like the
National Enquirer in the United States I
mean that's that was one of the biggest
selling publications in the United
States for a very long time and it had
stuff that was completely made-up in it
and
reddit and it was and it was
entertaining and maybe they believed a
little bit maybe they didn't but they
were sort of happy with it because it
gave them that moment and this is
something that I hear a lot about and
it's also something that when I talk to
the people who do fake news for a living
commercially-driven one not even the
political stuff but just making up the
crazy stories that people like to share
you know for them they argue there's no
harm people whether they believe it or
not it doesn't really change anything
but you know there's different segments
to it so one of them is if it's about
politics and it changes people's
perception of the world around them or
how they vote then obviously that that
would be a huge concern the other one
that I see a lot of just to give one
example is that a lot of safe news
stories the United States use people's
mug shots
so someone picks a mug shot and maybe
it's a kind of an extreme photo or funny
photo and the next thing you know people
who create fake news will grab that
photo and pair with a completely made-up
story and so in that sense is there a
cost to society
well that may be that's hard it argued
then that actual person who maybe you
know committed a crime or in the end
might have been acquitted or never fully
charged with this and all of a sudden
their photo lives on an EM to me on the
internet so I think there can absolutely
be different degrees of consequences we
also have to consider what the overall
societal cost is if we have more and
more of the nonsense and face stuff
getting as much traction and some pages
more virality than the free then the
real stuff what what does that do to us
over time the cumulative effect I think
is is something that concerns me right
and I was going to get to you on this
Tim but others might want to jump in
this point about how we make decisions
is the authority this is like their exam
about the crime commanders example of
the crime figures and Newt Gingrich and
the crime figure if we actually don't
know what the crime figures are it's
very hard to drop a criminal justice
policy yeah so you need people to agree
on a basic set of facts yeah with that
in mind and I'm going to do this partly
and I will give you a chance to come
back though because of some of the
things you've written about climate
change somebody who denies quietly Matt
human-made climate change would you want
to say that's under this different
opinion or would you want to slap a fake
news label on that I might there was a
lot in the United States of corporate
propaganda you know I think some of the
greatest propagandists are
are our corporations and I think when
it's disingenuous when it you know sort
of representative you have a tiny
percentage and exaggerate sit into a
debate as that is propaganda that is
fake news and that so you resist I don't
think if she censored but I think it
should be called what it is I want to
also to take great exception to this
view that you know fake news is
something that everyone does and you
know Blair did and so forth I think that
that understates the problem
significantly I think that fake news and
propaganda is always the tool of the
extremists now I agree that you'll have
it on the far left the Soviet Union used
a lot of fake news on its citizens and
you know the German Third Reich use it
on their citizens but it is always a
tool of someone who doesn't have a
better argument you know why do you go
to fake news is because you can't win
the argument in the center why is their
client changed the nihilism is because I
can't win the regular scientific debate
right why the corporation's resort to
inventing in the United States or
inventing campaigns and you know even
now having robots who comment it's
because you can't win the political
debate and that is a grave danger for an
open society that relies on the idea of
public opinion mattering because it
moves people back to like well maybe we
have to completely count the public out
and just have them out of it and have
experts decide that's what that's what
some people start thinking about it no I
think it's a grave danger to the
building society to make decisions at
all if you want have an open this
society that makes good decisions you
really need to fight propaganda hard
very good I mean by James should come
back on your position on fake news sorry
your position on climate change some
have branded to be quickly Kim had two
shots didn't he actually before mine and
the first one he did the clever
rhetorical crit well is what a devious
rhetorical trick where he said yeah
we've had cancer with us for a long time
so like like faint news is like can
seize planted that idea in your mind
what about faint news is like bad
weather it's been with us all the time
you can even even we can both play these
games
um I crave something just briefly the
government on his point so I just think
the case has been made that fake news is
a bad thing I really don't one of
Craig's arguments was that that people
are making money out of it well my
goodness anyone who works in the media
today knows how downtown is to make
money out of any form of journal
if kids in Macedonia are making a living
by making stuff up
I say fair play to the kids of Macedonia
but to return to to Tim's deeply
objectionable point ah this I was going
to vote this later on but but since
we're here we may as well
well go there this is the arrogance of
the the liberal media thinking that its
version of events is the correct one he
can't even countenance the possibility
that those on this skeptical side of the
climate argument might actually be right
mine actually Marshall evidence to
support their their case and it seems to
me that he's missing a key element of
what journalism is about it is about
making a case whether you're on the left
or the right that is your job doesn't
matter what label you attach to it it is
about making a case using arguments lose
use using logic lose using quotes from
people that you've gathered but the idea
is that team can just suddenly declare
that this is kind of he implied funded
by sinister interest that's just me
quite wrong because that's his opinion
but I don't think that it is the only
opinion I think there are other valid
opinions out there okay whether you just
edited opinion but what if those facts
and evidence and data that you can draw
on it's interesting you say that well in
one of the more lamentable trends in our
universities in the last 20 years and
this is what lyrical bloom rose about
wrote about is is is the resisting
relativism that there was no such thing
as truth actually I think the job of
journalists has been and always will be
ultimately to try and find the truth
it's just that it's not necessarily what
people from the New York Times say it is
there are other well I mean I would
argue that I'm right
basically all right we would turn no no
it's not the whole climate change we
mustn't do that well you write my phone
not my bad I just wanted to talk about
the the issue itself rather than
drilling into it but Amanda you wanted
to come in right agree well okay
so much to kind of come in on now right
Wang back that's all accusing people who
make great use of of Carrodus of not
wanting to take part in the discussion
in the debate is is fine but we have to
apply that to both sides of the argument
I think for too many too many occasions
people on the odds of a better phrase
the liberal left have concluded that
they are right in any argument and that
things are obvious and that those who
don't agree with them are supplying
falsehoods
for example I've altered remain and I
was deeply disappointed that Rex had
happened but I was absolutely shocked by
the attitude of Kira mainers for quite
some time which is we just got it wrong
because our argument is the true
argument and I think you have to fight
against that and I knew there was
another 350 million which well exactly
all I'm saying is what type but I think
I think it's i think it's lazy to think
that all these facts exists for example
in the climate change are doing yes
truth is difficult to find but there are
facts and I think I think you form your
opinion on climate change on examining
the facts I think it's people who argue
in favor of climate change forget that
they have to keep reminding people of
how they arrived at that conclusion the
onus is on us or whoever is supplying
that opinion to keep backing it up you
can't just state that it's obvious and
therefore I don't have to do anything
this is going to be briefer on the book
this particular issue the BBC was used
to have a thing where if there was an
opinion offered they would say some
people say this others say that a
critics argued has there been any
discussion of EVC about weather or let's
say the example of the crowd sizes of
Donald Trump's inauguration I know where
anybody who looked at the photographs
thought that that crowd was smaller than
that crowd but would the BBC still feel
the need to say according to Donald
Trump that was the bigger crowd or would
the BBC feel confident saying that was
the bigger crowd you know when Paul is
what where have you come to yeah well I
I've only been here three
week so I'm not sure I can speak to the
BBC yet and it's an insulin one say that
cry because I do remember supercells
more picking up on how often crowd sizes
are and that we take a figure that with
isn't verified and I think the example
he gave of all these was the March that
came afterwards which was described as
millions had anyone checked you know I
think on the whole people except from a
picture that you can see there weren't
that many people but there wasn't a
there wasn't a totally satisfactory
figure but I agree just saying one
person says this one person says that
you don't want sort of critics argue
that the wall around no I think what you
want you know inspector actually what
you wanted the kind of some spirit of
scientific inquiry do you want to be
open and I think that is the thing a
brexit because actually what was
interesting there and notice that having
said you're wrong and then the
implication was so you're wrong so
you're realize you're wrong and you'll
feel remorseful and interestingly that
didn't happen you know there's actually
people and became more convinced that
the brexit is became more convinced they
were right you know there was there
wasn't the remorse that everyone's
expecting so it doesn't work if you just
fight if you just fight it in terms of
opinion I think you just have to go back
to the beginning as you say and and
start making a case so we just got us
nicely to where I wanted us to pivot
which is into remedies and solutions
we're just going to take it for the sake
of this part of the argument that there
is a problem here to be addressed so
naturally I'm going to look to you Jimmy
because you've got into the business now
of proposing a solution besides your own
project with wiki Tribune what else in
the broader news universe needs to
happen to deal in this problem so yeah I
was going to say that I can talk about
the things I won't solve but I think
there are pieces of the puzzle that are
out there that need to be solved and one
of the biggest is things spreading
virally through Facebook and what
happens there more than anything else is
that news fake news stories and let's
pick something uncontroversially just
completely made-up hope endorses Trump
got shared you know tens of thousands of
times and what happens is then these
websites they look like new
website they've got all the signifiers
as a masthead and some ads and it looks
like a news and pile on and so on and it
spreads virally through communities of
people who are not avid news junkies and
I think it's perfectly valid in the
world that some people shouldn't have to
pay attention to the news that's not for
everybody and that's okay and the
problem is in a slightly different set
of historical facts we might be sitting
up here all freaking out that Facebook
has decided to determine for us which
news we should be seeing that sort of
unbelievable power of Facebook to shape
the dialogue is something that people on
the left and on the right and I think
all parts of political spectrum it makes
us nervous that that's really like very
big Brotherhood and at the same time we
kind of want Facebook to help do
something about this and I do think
there are things that they can do that
are okay so me one of the things I want
Facebook to do if I'm if I'm about to
share something and it's been debunked
by third party fact checkers and it's
sort of well known that this is a
problem I just want them to warn me to
say you know something to the effect of
you might be about to look like an idiot
in front of your friends you might want
to go check this before you share it a
lot of people said this is fake and then
let me share it if I want to and that's
that's slightly mild and gentle enough
to just give a warning now and then
that's invariant if you get that one
just before you press send or whatever
pressure share but what about should you
just appear on facebook saying this has
been flagged up as topic but but this is
there is a really difficult thing if
it's just this has been flagged as fake
then you get brigades of people just
flagging stuff as being say because they
don't like it they don't like you get
you don't want a situation he may write
a column an opinion piece about climate
change where he sort of whatever puts
forth his views that you know I don't
really want Facebook to sort of flag up
his opinion as being problematic and you
couldn't shoot me there's the problem
right you know and that's my family hard
as a liberal vibe solutely well you know
obviously people on the other something
and be be seeping out people on the
other side of that I'll Facebook I think
objectively speaking it does have a
liberal well that's good to Craig sopin
because I've wanted you from you were on
we're on remedies now
what what do we want from Facebook and
Google are obviously absolutely central
in disseminating this information it was
big argument started here when somebody
typed in essentially about the Holocaust
and Google came back with a whole set of
answers that directed you to Holocaust
denial website so what do we want from
Google what do we want from Facebook to
Ukraine well I think one piece of is to
go with the point that's been made
previously is is I part of what we want
is also what we don't want which is is
them stepping in and exerting even more
influence over things and so for me I
think the first step is well what I want
is transparency from them as the first
step because if there are people who
feel they have a liberal bias if there
are people to feel that you know they
favor some pages over other pages the
only way for them to address that is to
actually be far more transparent than
they are and the only way that we can be
assured of the things that they're going
to do the technical measures to adjust
the algorithms and other thing to lower
the distribution of fake stuff the only
way we can be assured about you know
they're not being crazy unintended
consequences from that is for more
transparency so that's that's probably
the first speech I think they do have a
technical responsibility to you Thanks
I'm wary of putting you know any more
power in their hands I think especially
in Facebook's case seven months ago
before the US election they did not
really want to engage on this topic they
wanted to stay away from it as much as
possible now they're engaging which on
one level is good but on the other level
and we have to be hugely concerned
because when they make an algorithm
squeak it changes the fortunes of places
it changes the different information
that people see so they have a role I
think Facebook is right to go after the
a hundred percent face up and to not
completely create black lists and other
things that threaten free speech but I
think step one is more transparency from
them about not just what they're doing
but how that's being implemented and
then actually giving data to third party
researchers so they can analyze what's
actually going on you know the last part
of it is that these platforms are so big
Facebook and Google don't know
everything that's happening on their
platforms it's actually impossible for
them to do that so we need more third
parties to have access to the data to
actually say hey we found some huge
problems here that you guys need to
address ranging what you say about
transparency The Guardian did reveal
this week and so-called facebook files
which showed
the manuals and Facebook you're using it
was quite striking what they were their
own guidance to their own moderators
about what they'd allow through and what
they wouldn't - you can win then I want
to just go around a bit a little bit on
what we should do our cells and then
we're going to open up so just a brief
answer from YouTube this idea that
should Facebook Google be sort of have
to come out as publishers the admit that
they are no different really from the
BBC or the Guardian or the New York
Times and take all the responsibility
that goes over know absolutely so first
of all I want to say if it's the
arrogance to speak for the truth and I
will plead guilty you know I think I
feel a very solid ground saying that to
respond as other things that we need
people fighting for the truth and we
have drifted very far I cancer may be
too far but we have recurrent problems
that come propaganda and seeped into our
new system because of the uncertainty
because of the change of business model
so we need to fight it and I'm not
ashamed to say that at all
as for what Google and Facebook should
be doing I because I'm an American I I
feel I can say this that the American
faith and transparency is is way
overstated and transparency remedies do
nothing you know like look at privacy
for example oh you know you have to be
transparent about how invasive you are
people's privacy does that stop anything
no people just click and be like okay
I've just given away all my privacy I
don't think big news gets cured at all
by transparency regimes I think that
fundamentally you know you keep saying
we don't want to get facebook any more
power the power is already there you
want to give Facebook power quit or
break them up don't be like oh you can't
do something they are already a leading
media power it's too late if that's
going to be the problem
they're already creating the media
environment we live in so they need to
clean up their act and be a little more
responsible Marvel Comics with great
power comes great responsibility you
know they're already doing it they're
they're doing a huge amount to create
this environment I think they have to
clean up their act and not you know fool
around with transparency algorithms but
how should we be made to clean up their
act because I'm not saying they should
make you I think they should take the I
think they are beginning to do this and
I think they need to take the ethical
responsibility of saying
it's not like one hand on the other hand
there is this thing called fake news it
happens you know like what he's trying
to do that what we you know they're
making billions now maybe they can
compare themselves with Wikipedia and
feel a sense of shame
I mean Wikipedia I think is a model in
this world you don't talk here about
Wikipedia keishon of people sabotaging
things a lot of love for Wikipedia I
mean you have occasional sabotage and we
have your problem but you don't have
stuff sticking around forever that's
completely absolutely off the off the
scale you do have entries for comic book
heroes which are longer than from a bear
historical figures which is a little bit
of an issue and minor bit characters on
popular dramas but I can deal with that
but I think Wikipedia despite all the
cracks trusted source whatever Wikipedia
did Facebook can do - they have you know
one way or another figured out this
problem and I sort of I hate this
equivocating oh we're gonna do something
small I think they need to take action
thank you there's much more I would also
review but I want to hear now from our
audience so we're going to have people
with microphones moving among you do you
put up your hand if you would like me to
come to you let's get and probably keep
your hands there until I can see okay
my chronometry do you have someone there
you've already got someone answered
looks good let's keep that way and
you've already got so there's somebody
at number one which is good and let's
bring you through the third microphone
or map some mic for number one when you
finish find another person there but
let's hear from the person who's already
yeah um thank you so much really really
fascinating I just wanted to ask the
question and just hear opinions really
if you think that part of the problem is
calling everything news you've kind of
all alluded at some points that some of
it's just content some of it's
entertainment some of it's an opinion
piece so are we kidding ourselves as
readers that are we letting ourselves be
misled and placing the blame on on
journalism and news organizations and
actually we should say we've just
watched a really crazy video it's not
now you know not news aghhhhhh no really
interesting thank you
let's hear the question number two yeah
just to pick up on Tim's point there
Jimmy if you could Wikipedia Facebook
how would you do it and by Wikipedia
Facebook meaning make it a wiki model is
that what you mean yeah thumbs up still
there thank you and then we've got
question number three somebody's already
there yeah it's really a follow-on from
the first question that you've referred
to it as fake news and propaganda why
not lies and where do you see the
distinction thank you well let's let's
go with that first
Armondo to you why do we not just call
this stuff lives rather than these very
convoluted formulation of post truth or
lies but you know everyone's been saying
it sold as a form of entertainment
that's a part of the power of the
problem is the medium now means that we
I start off the very first TV show I did
was fake news the day-to-day is a spoof
news program but it so that my face that
was fair but but yeah the horses on the
underground everything it was all false
but we could do that then because we
knew what the news was there was a
commonly agreed idea of what the news
was it was Jerry Pat's remembers the
BBC's ITV you know the news eight lights
outlets were there were only four or
five main news channels and no not just
a spread of 24-hour news and online news
but the fact that the medium itself the
the the web allows anyone to make
anything look like it's the Guardian or
everything is now looks like it's of the
same it gives authority to anything
that's the problem
this was Jimmy's pointed out how a story
on Facebook actually can look I know
different former Guardian on yeah yeah
and it might just see this guardian oh
yeah Dressen was the Denver Guardian yes
it's a perfect name because people have
heard of Denver at the city in America
but yeah who knows what the name of the
newspaper is yeah Guardian sounds like a
newspaper and it looked like it sounds
like a normal I'm not sure how that is
the problem is good bet the other thing
I feel is that because we know I just
wonder whether we got so used to the
idea that we can't believe anything
means that the whole world just feels
fake tears you know and the people who
wanted to
and protests elections and whatever i
doing partly because they think is this
real I don't know let's this push this
button and see what happens
what do you think Sarah about this use
of the word news would it be useful to
start using that word a bit less perhaps
and really narrow down what we meant by
me wasn't local infotainment at some
point but what happened to that you know
it's I guess if people is with the word
that they use naturally there's actually
if it's the way people use it's a
perfect fodder let's restore it it's
what people say oh I've got some news
you know and that and what we're talking
about is a complete democratization of
what people what people regard as news
so it's a tricky one you know you can
either I mean the BBC big sort of
trusted brand that people know so that
that's alright but I sort of have faced
that in the end you know the truth
settles and if you look at the arc of
the story even if it's a de Manchester
or something always starts with and
something something's happened which
everyone wants to know about there were
lots and lots of information some right
some wrong some theories right sometimes
or finally you you you you get a picture
of what really happens so it's just
whether you're prepared to be patient I
think a news is when you actually know
what happened let's just some do a
little bit of another survey here for a
second which is it could raise your hand
if you feel you have ever even on a very
small level being taken in by something
that you later realize was fake news I
don't find it I put my hand up to you
for that good so it's quite a good
number it keep your hand up if you would
like to tell us about and you know
you've just got an example Jimmy why
don't you tell us your one while we look
for other people yell yeah this is a
good one and probably I think the
Evening Standard was taken in by as well
there was a story drop on the Evening
Standard
go go I'm not having a go in anybody I
was saying no but part of the point is
it is easy to be taken in and one of the
things that said here is the story was a
story from Jackson Mississippi about a
couple they were trying to have a child
they were having trouble conceiving they
went in for fertility treatments and as
a part of the testing they discovered
that they were twins Wow like that's
heavy and it's a great human interest
story it also pretty much reflects most
people's view of what Jackson
Mississippi must be like I'm from
Alabama trust me I know
and yet with a little bit of closer
inspection you see them they didn't name
the doctor they didn't name the clinic
after the story was published in and was
picked up by several news outlets
including sadly the Evening Standard
it was debunked quite quickly and turns
out it was a variant of the story that
had appeared on a notorious fake news
site in the spring and it was just it
was such a great story that people said
oh yeah and it was also plausible it was
the Mississippi Herald plausible
sounding name for a thing and it's not
that hard to get taken in by some of
this stuff so when we were doing the
radio version of the data they only are
we really within 10 seconds came close
to getting a screw story on the Today
program that we had made about cows
rising from the dead in an abattoir in
bristle and it was all it was all set to
go and John Humphries was writing his
introduction to it when the day editor
said who wrote this story again and it
was Chris Morris Oh
where he must be the way of that
craziness and satirizing this before
anyone else along with you I mean
someone else putting your hand up with
an example of a fake news experience
they've had so lady here is waving a
hand if we can bring the microphone to
you it's going to get the atmosphere of
sort of people testifying in a
revivalist Church okay it's me after he
lapsed into sin and then we'll come to
number three in a minute yeah um I was
somewhat taken in briefly by pizza gate
and I still have my doubts because it
was never actually properly debunked
what was he referring to in
those emails it was code for something
and I think it's a great example of
where an argument was not made to
counter I mean obviously the ritual
sacrifice stuff is nonsense but I still
have quite rock was it drug what there
was a code going on in those emails
what was it I mean the reason partly why
I mentioned bought it up was because
there was an example of fake news with
consequences because as you remember an
armed man went in with you know an
automatic weapon and was ready to kill
people and you know was persuaded partly
because you've heard that there was a
child fix ring even making a plan and
there was no basement but let's just
hear from number person who's at
microphone number 3 yeah hi I think this
was faint news I'm still not 100% sure
but I saw and I saw a picture of Donald
Trump on my Facebook feed and next to it
was a quote that effectively said that
if I ever were to run for a political
party I would run for the Republicans
because they're the stupidest voters and
I think that was debunked oh yes by
children I felt like well you fell for
that as well because it and you fell for
it presumably cuz it tapped into
something you already believe it's that
thing of you you you gravitate towards
the stories that you really want to
believe in and you shy away from the
ones or you ignore the ones that dispute
what it is you believe in right quite
great children's been very patient I
want to go to you Craig on the question
that was put here in the hall which was
could you do a Wikipedia of Facebook
because we've heard that Wikipedia have
managed you know admirably to more or
less not always but weed out things that
are not true could that be done on
Facebook I so I think one one really big
challenge to start with is the scale of
Facebook the amount of content I think
it's something like 300 million links
shared every week on Facebook so if you
want to have humans do some kind of
review process on that it's probably not
scalable
however you could probably come up with
an idea to look something kind of like
what Facebook used to have for it's
trending product if you remember you
know you see the little list of trending
topics at one point they had a group of
editorial staffers who were kind of
validating the topic that the algorithm
would sort
spit out and things have decided to get
rid of them and they got rid of them
before their algorithm was good enough
to not promote stuff that was totally
false and obviously there were some
concerns that that in the selection of
those humans were they too liberal and
where they depressing conservative
sources was one piece of it so I think
are there human machine
combination models yes and if we're
talking about Facebook they do that to a
certain extent the way that they for
example suppress a clique base is that
they have actual humans doing the Drudge
work of human human labeling yes this is
a clickbait headlines that that you know
withhold information no this is not and
then the machines go and learn that and
then try to make their guesses so I kind
of say look has a bit of that but I
can't imagine they will ever want to
have editors in there because they'd be
humans as too messy as too hard to scale
and potentially to buy I might be
expensive but to me I wouldn't ask him
well how then does Facebook manage take
care of pornography and Google as well
you know I mean you would think that
this would be very attractive material
to a lot of viewers yet somehow they
magically men to weed it out but
magically they can't weed out other
things you know this has always been a
question for me on what if you have an
answer well I think so I think the stuff
that actually the Guardian leaked does
give us a bit of a roadmap on that is
that they have to have a bunch of humans
great rules of what is and what isn't
pornography or violence or what-have-you
and then they have to hire a bunch of
people to do it in combination with
algorithms so it's not impossible but I
do think one of the big has the patience
that that Facebook has been doing this
with news is that they're going to get
hammered from the left from the right on
it and I just think they're really
hesitant to do that overall I would say
however that you know Facebook recently
announced they're hiring three thousand
more people to do content review for
violence for pornography and that kind
of thing and I don't know what the
number is but I think they've got a hell
of a lot more people that they need to
hire because the platform is so big and
and the machines alone cannot do it to a
good enough degree as that I do think
they need to scale the human effort and
could they do it in news potentially
will they ever honestly I just I just
think they don't want to go anywhere
near that and as we said we did try and
get someone from Facebook here before I
get back to members of our audience I
want to ask you something Sarah
because you mentioned some I think it
was again that's your daughter booties
or somebody else but who said that they
checked Google News and then they go to
a more trusted provider we've been
talking mainly about what the providers
can do the producers of content is there
a burden on us the consumers of you
should do we need to get our act
together and only stick really and only
look at reputable verifiable online you
know journalism and perhaps take
responsibility for what we consume
rather than hoping of you know the great
face book in the sky is going to take
care of it for us yeah the consumers are
also they produces that's the point so
that sort of system journalism it so
it's a it's a fantastic thing but I
think you just have to remember that
pointed journalism is that you you're
trying to find things out and there's a
very good quote from David Harris be
prouder about sort of months -
proprietor where he said in my in my
house I have a library full of books
I've never read any of them because I've
already made up my mind and I think
that's the you know that's the point
that the true germ they should start by
wanting to find something out not going
with with preconceptions because they
you subtract sure and the question doing
away to consumers of use is there a
bigger responsibility on us to to very
to filter what we look at more more
rigorously let's save some hands often
when people have got questions there's a
gentleman there would be wearing a white
shirt I think let's go to you and then
we'll carry on yeah well it really
follows on from that question I wonder
if we completely miss identifying the
problem st. News has been around forever
technology may have increased its
velocity but fate needs has been around
forever so perhaps we should zoom out
and maybe the problem is the state of is
education perhaps you know are we our
education systems are too focused on
rote learning and following instructions
perhaps we're not equipped to
interrogate facts think tangentially
numeracy amongst other wise very
intelligent people is terrible if you
can't work out what six zeros are for a
number
is and divide it by the approximate size
of the economy how can you sort of think
about anything a politician says
contagious toggling over the level here
so perhaps we miss identifying the
problem by talking about the
perpetrators or via fake news and that
is more a societal problem yes Thank You
Simon by number four we've got a
question there and yeah this is about
responsibility again and whether that's
on the consumer or the purveyor of
information
I just wanted if man allowed any views
about whether or not sites such as let's
use space because the example should be
mandated to and I know times that the
transparency doesn't work but the fact
is the two billion people use this
platform and most of the people who use
this like count most of the people in
this room amongst them don't understand
what happens when they click stuff and
when they write stuff and what that
means about how likely it is that other
people are going to see it it's not just
about pressing share on something every
time you write a comment under an
article on Facebook even if the comment
is this is why you were
commenting on this it makes it more
likely that other people are going to
see that they might not see you're
commenting is they're just more
likely to see it people doesn't know
that people don't get it is there a duty
of care on Facebook to at least reveal
how that stuff works thank you and five
position number two yeah thanks very
much doing this tonight my question is
interesting to hear folks talk about
this has been around for a long time
maybe it's Google and Facebook's fault
but I guess a question for each panelist
scale of one to ten is this an issue in
our society today because one politician
gave this news currency who you talking
about that you know okay
Teresa may
he did use the sense a claim right we
did what did she not talk about fake
claims this week she didn't a friend she
keeps showing me Corwin of making fake
claims about her policy so microphone
number three um so Tim mentioned Blair
really really briefly but do you not
think that after the Chilkoot inquiry
people would just naturally not trust
the british media that supported the
Iraq war since it's been proved that
Blair was mostly lying about a lot of
those claims just to me thank you they
will be obviously people will question
that too and I want to get one more than
one or two more in we just had a run as
mail the question is I'm quite keen
people who see me do this before to have
a bit of a gender balance so let's get
going number one no I think whether
people are standing up but I wonder
whether there's a combination of both
the Wikipedia of kind of model for
Facebook and also responsibility on
consumers and I say that because I
remember one of my dad shared a Britain
first thing on Facebook and I wrote
saying I'm not sure whether you kept the
source of this and I think people don't
necessarily know where things are coming
from but it might take their family
members and friends to kind of maybe
explain things or maybe there's a
responsibility on family members and
friends to to do this to point out yes
interesting thank you this might be the
last one I'm afraid of mine for number
three there we go hi I want to go back
to the gentleman who raised at that
point about zooming out a bit and for me
this feels a bit that it's about stories
and storytelling and I wonder what you
think too so personally since breakfast
I've retreated from news reading and
started reading a lot of fantasy books
and actually that's really and I didn't
I hadn't noticed I was doing it I picked
up and I wondered if there's something
about how maybe where we are at this
point as a Western society where maybe
we lack that bigger narrative that
clarity about where we're going maybe
it's a bit easier to sink into these
smaller stories that are more compelling
and easy
I think that's certainly thank you for
all of those questions and what I'm
going to do we're at the point where
we're going to get closing remarks from
all of you but I will ask you all to
just you know address one at least one
of the questions that came up as we do
so so you're actually first up to this
James and what let me see if there's one
any of these question because I why
don't you choose in fact unit out
because it most like we have somebody
there suggest that a person who bears
big responsibility for this is Donald
Trump because I think even you James
would concede he has not always been
scrupulous about that now I think he's
great I think it's that I know you think
it's great but he hasn't won I think the
dress doesn't put up no and if it works
nice you said I was I could also which
question I wanted I liked the girl who
said that she's turned to family normal
so I think that probably george RR
martin has more to tell us about
contemporary politics then then any any
newspaper click very very seat raised
two really key points which no one's
mentioned and I think it's wrong sad one
is we have experiment at the beginning
where you were asked you were all asked
which of the these three stories you
believed most of you knew which was the
fake news story I think I think we're
forgetting sometimes the wisdom of
crowds that people are actually capable
of discerning and there is this kind of
elitist assumption that people are thick
they don't know what's good for them
therefore they need these signposts from
from the authorities from Facebook I'm
not sure I agree with that
and the second thing is that there's a
concerning issue about about censorship
and freedom of speech after all our John
Milton wrote in Areopagitica
defense of free speech and one of the
things he said is that bad ideas need to
be out there being exposed so that we
can discern the bad ideas from the good
ideas and I think we're in danger of
forgetting that in favor of an
authoritarianism run by people who are
not used judgement is not necessarily
any better than the people their partial
judgement on okay thank you
equally concise if you can sarah fans to
you what about this some
notion that let me have a look to see
which one I want to put to you well
about education should it now be part of
children's education in this country
that they learn to interrogate social
media and Facebook and what pops up on
their phone
should that be actually something that
is part of the curriculum yeah I think
actually was a really good idea and that
should be part of Education anyway of
assistive training a mine too and to
interrogate you know back to this sense
of inquiry so that sounded I'm very
sensible to me the other thing I would
just say that some up and slightly
supporting for James on this I do think
people will work we're in pretty
uncharted territory and all this you
know there's a huge amount of
information we've seen already this
light to quality we've seen that people
actually do value and expertise when
what when they when they they just have
to see who they trust but we know
actually scientists are pretty trusted
we know teachers are pretty trusted we
know doctors are pretty trusted and so I
think you know in the end I'm pretty
optimistic about it all I think and as
they say the sort of truth comes out it
differently it is just not immediate so
closing thought from you Armando and I
thought you might perhaps address this
point the question arrays which is the
deem what did the drop set in with Iraq
and and the you know the you mentioned
Tony Blair yourself before not just the
politicians who said there were weapons
of mass destruction but the media that
did row in behind them did that mean
that media lost a lot of credibility
interest well and prepare the ground for
debate it was the perfect storm of an
administration which you know had a huge
majority so could have actually done
quite a lot but was obsessed with the
media and it was a media that was
obsessed with getting access to the
government and it was an administration
that was upset with trying obsessed with
trying to control the agenda so all of
those sort of little elements there as
the brewing brewed into the
distinguished their acting which was
strangely enough for a politician who
had spent all his time trying to work
out what people wanted it's the first
time he acted on his own belief and they
do me Schreck and completely ignored
what everyone was telling him what it
was
all right I want to pick up on the
education thing actually because there's
nothing we haven't really discussed
which is we should not just debate
social media we should debate debate I I
mean they used to be funny that I grew
up in subscribe to baiting tradition and
those really fantastic the fantastic
discipline to have a proposal to debate
it for 10 minutes and then to be told 10
minutes in to swap sides and have to
think in the mind of your opponent and I
think we shy away from having
discussions with people who disagree
with us if we actually believe if we
have confidence in our own faith and our
own conclusions they should be able to
withstand attack from someone else and I
think what we do instead is retreat to
those who agree with us and we see
anyone who disagrees with us not just as
an opponent but it's somehow offensive
that were being offended at our views
are being ridiculed and in fact they're
not they're being challenged and we
should be confident enough we should be
confident about facts if we believe in
facts we should be confident enough to
use them I'd really like to bring in
addition to like tinder and Grindr and
sender and all these other but I I want
to propose an app an app that puts you
in touch with someone who is
diametrically opposite views yes
I'm cold
I call it ponder swipe left or swipe
right you could do either that's a
really good idea there I'm guessing in
this room is probably half a dozen
internet startup entrepreneurs already
quietly stepping out to set that up and
Craig Selma I you're obviously closing
remarks for me but one thing I wanted to
put to you was the question about from
the woman who said she found herself her
word retreating from news and reading
fantasy instead and he just put in my
mind this idea that we you know there is
a tendency perhaps more pronounced on
the liberal or left end of the spectrum
so really obsess over facts and doesn't
mean that people have on that side of
the oven it's forgotten the power and
appeal of story and narrative and
actually maybe that's what the decide
that you know one might want a brand
fake news have going for them is they do
know the power of storytelling and
perhaps the other side is just in the
business of selling dry facts that are
so dry people end up running off to read
fantasy instead there is I think a real
challenge and also a difference between
the sort of emotion driven side which is
really what performs well on Facebook
and the very clinical
you know bloodless facts only side and
and this is one of the challenges that
we have of just knocking down this
information in general is that when you
come at it from the pose of the debunker
which is something I do a lot you just
look like a know-it-all and you look
like an annoying person wagging your
finger at everyone and if you're just
doing an impure leaf actual term you
can't really compete with emotion and
and so I think there's a lot of complex
things going on but a lot of it I've
talked a lot about platforms with
technology and that kind of thing and
the core of it is really you know human
our emotions the way our brains work we
are drawn to things that align with what
we already thinking what we already feel
and and the algorithm is aspirate that
so well I think people are not only
retreating to fantasy but they're also
retreating into kind of their own
ideological bubble and you know the last
thing I would just say is I think this
has come up a couple of times where
people focus on conservatives in the
right and they're fake news
but since Trump has been elected if you
look at the really hyper partisan
liberal Facebook pages and websites they
are getting huge engagement because now
they have an enemy and there is
absolutely a lot of misinformation
coming from that side as well now and so
again it's not it's not even about the
sides it's about us as humans and how we
interact with the information in the
world around us and that's at the core
of this challenge that's why it's been
around forever but when those things
become mediated by algorithms on huge
platforms suddenly it takes on another
approach so it is a complex problem and
it comes down to us as humans I think at
the end of the day thank you Kim we're
closing thought from you one of the
questions that game what was whether
there should be some kind of
responsibility on Facebook that they
when you're posting to the user should
know more about what's going to happen
to the piece that they post you know
that how it's going to get seen and it's
going to go viral even if they are
trying to debunk that piece right now I
think it's optimistic to expect people
to understand the algorithms of Facebook
I if I can choose my question I also
want to make a comment on this this the
book you know though the retreat to
books not only because I'm an author but
I think there's another message in there
which is we are too dependent on news as
entertainment
you know we somehow have some to think
that news has to be you know
entertaining if you want entertaining
then you read books and maybe you don't
need to spend all your think about how
you spend your time and attention and
whether you spend it why do you need to
always be on on Facebook you know can
you can you start at that level and I
think that's an important observation we
demand too much from our news that it be
too entertaining for us um you know I
personally write books about the broad
sweep of history and you know the rise
and tall's of civilizations and I think
these issues are really serious and I
think the Iraq war comment really brings
it slightly to a head that you know
people are saying what big news took you
in that was the most important clearly
that was the worst or the most important
fake news in the last 20 years you know
even more than know some random story
but pizza gate or whatever you know I
was taking in I think a huge number of
people believed that Iraq had weapons of
mass destruction or they can inclusive
or
or a nuclear bomb in a briefcase and so
an open society made to open societies
at least made some of the worst
decisions they've ever made you know 100
you know so many people died on the
basis of fake news that is the cost of
fake news in a nutshell trillions of
dollars spent tens of thousands of
people dying because of something
someone made up that for political
reasons and that's what I'm scared about
in our environment
I believe that the creation over the
long term and the objective media of
something called a journalist as
profession is a serious achievement of
civilization and we are facing it's
unraveling and I think we need to fight
it if open societies are going to
continue to have an advantage John
Stuart Mill's idea of the advantage of
open societies was that they are able to
debate to ideas and come to a better
conclusion but that presupposes an
actual real debate based on real facts
where you have for one thing massive
amounts of money spent to distort the
debate and second you know the arbiters
of facts being distorted you have a
grave risk I think for the future of our
civilization so I take this issue
seriously and I'm even more concerned to
see over the next four years I mean
you're optimistic that you you live here
I got to get back on a plane where you
know it's just getting started and you
have a commander-in-chief who has
understood the most powerful techniques
of propaganda frankly a fascist fascist
enterprise to try to force the people to
listen to what he has to say all the
time I lived in what I think is a free
society ice nonetheless see the great
leaders picture every day like ten times
and his slogans and United States is in
serious trouble and I think it's those
who value freedom it's their time to
fight
thank you
thank you very much just for the record
because this point of view we ought to
be at least Express I'm sure if Tony
Blair were here he would say wasn't fake
news he'd seen evidence and they came to
that clusion he believed it with I was
actually blaming the American Shore just
just if anyone is after was gonna
challenge azimuth yeah okay so that's it
I'm just think what he would say if you
were here which is not like Facebook
he's not here tonight and let's go to
you Jimmy wells I think the last thing
that Tim said there QG up nicely because
we didn't answer the question that came
over there about what role Donald Trump
has played in it are we in a way talking
about saying is because of him would we
have done it otherwise and there was
also this the only question left
unanswered the contribution from over
there suggesting that family members
people close to people not an algorithm
but a not a machine but other friends
and family members could could play a
role in saying you know what don't post
that it's not real that you're closing
fluids yeah I means on on that point
term ask the question you know Facebook
deals with pornography but the truth is
none of my friends are posting
pornography I don't know what kind of
friends you got them but
that just doesn't happen right and so
and the other question you know how how
could some pieces of the Wikipedia model
be applied here for me that's about
genuine community control and I don't
have an easy answer for Facebook on that
but I do think one of the things that
they could do algorithmically that would
be purely opt-in purely voluntary it's
very similar to your app idea is if they
one morning I've got up and I got on
Facebook and they said new option do you
want this instead of just showing you
things that we think you're going to
like we want to show you some things
that we think you're going to disagree
with but appear to be quality because I
would love to get out of my filter
bubble all right
living in London I just thought well
there's no way breakfast is going to
pass like everybody I know you know and
the end of the meeting and everything
else no I've missed a lot I'm miss what
was going on and I would love to get out
of my filter bubble and I do think that
Facebook for purely business reasons not
as a matter of regulatory being forced
to do so they need to improve the
quality of my experience there and if I
feel like Facebook is misleading me
because all my friends agree with me and
therefore I'm not being challenged
intellectually that's a problem I want
to be challenged intellectually because
that's what the future depends on thank
you I think it's been a real total
result from our stellar panel tons to
think about here and I think pretty well
all of it accurate and truthful so I'm
sure you're going to enjoy me in
thanking all of our guests and people
here Tim woo I'm under your new tree
Sara fans came to the hall said well
they still work
thank you all thank you